Hi, I'm Peter.
And six years ago,
I received information that changed
the course of the rest of my life.
From 1969 through 2001,
the US government
murdered over 12 billion birds
in the American skies.
They did this using poisonous toxins
dropped from airplanes
that was contagious
and murdered all of the birds
over the course of about 40 years.
Now, I know this is not the public
understanding of this
and may sound absurd,
but please just bear with me
and keep an open mind
and just be respectful, please,
as I share this information with you.
I know a lot of you may be wondering
why would the government
kill 12 billion birds?
It seems like an awful lot of trouble
for a government to go through.
The reason is as devastating
as it is simple.
For each bird the government killed,
they replaced it with a surveillance
drone replica in disguise
designed to spy on the American people.
Now ...
Some may say,
if you're the government, at least,
that this is a worthy sacrifice,
these 12 billion lives,
for the safety of the people, right?
I don't know about that,
it seems like a pretty serious
limit on our freedom,
wouldn't you agree?
The proof that birds are robots
is all around us, if you start looking.
For starters, birds charge
their batteries on power lines --
(Laughter)
So they can refuel up high
and they can watch
the civilians, you know.
They also track civilians
using a liquid tracking device.
(Laughter)
You ever wonder
why birds poop on your car?
Do you need more evidence?
Really, I can go all day up here.
Who here has seen a baby pigeon?
You haven't, have you?
It's weird.
There's all these adult pigeons
where are all the babies?
They come out of the factory
as adults, so ...
(Laughter)
There's no organic growth, you know.
It's a smoking gun.
Over the years,
as I began putting
this information together,
I began realizing the extent of all this.
And there were times I wished
I never even learned this.
My life would be so much easier.
You know, I remember before
I knew this information, I was happier,
my steps were lighter, you know.
But I always come back to this.
It is my moral obligation
as one of the few
privileged enough to know this,
to share it with you,
the blind sheep, you know.
(Laughter)
And that's what I've been
doing for years now.
I'm a part of a movement
called Birds Aren't Real.
And in 2021,
I was promoted to public
information officer for the movement.
It's the honor of my life.
I had one job.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you.
My one job was to deprogram
the public from the bird lie.
And deprogram is a very specific word
because you all are programmed.
You know that, right?
We live in a pro-bird civilization
drenched in propaganda.
For instance, every state
has a state bird,
the national mascot is a bald eagle,
presidents don't talk, they tweet,
then the tweets are covered
on the bird-logo media.
Once I knew this,
my first order of business
was to get the information out
to the American people,
get off the internet into the real world.
So that's what I did.
I bought a van,
covered it in decals with facts.
I wanted to turn the highway
into an information highway,
awaken the people.
I went city to city, holding rallies,
meeting up with our thousands
of supporters, growing by the day.
And I was putting up billboards
wherever we went,
sharing our simple but powerful message.
Look how beautiful it is.
Now, the government,
(Laughter)
the government did take note
of what we were doing
and they sent some intimidators
to try and deter us from our mission.
You can see them right there.
(Laughter)
But we did not fold.
We kept on going.
We started holding rallies at some
of the most evil pro-bird corporations
in the world, starting with Twitter,
where we brought hundreds out
to protest their pro-bird logo.
Months later, we brought 500 people
out to CNN headquarters
to demand fairer coverage
for bird truthers on air.
Then just last year,
we brought 2,000 people out
to Washington Square in New York City
to demand that the mayor
shut down every pigeon in the city.
(Laughter)
Here's what that looked like.
(Crowd shouting) Birds aren't real!
Birds aren't real!
(Laughter)
Can't even tell you how that felt.
I took that video standing on the top
of the van, megaphone in hand,
knowing we were awakening a country
that needs it so badly.
I can't think of anything more beautiful.
OK, let me start this talk over.
I do not actually believe
that birds are robots.
And everyone else in this picture
is also in on the bit.
This is a character
that I played for four years.
The leader of a fake movement
with fake evidence and a fake history.
Our goal was to convince the public
that our satirical movement
was a real one.
And see if the media would believe
what we were saying.
To do this, I played this character
that I just showed you.
We held rallies, put up billboards.
We even sent the media
a lot of fake evidence.
We hired an old actor
to pose as an ex-CIA agent
confessing to his crimes.
We sent them a historic email leak
called "Poultry Gate"
that came out of the Pentagon,
(Laughter)
where we forged hundreds of fake emails
exposing elites and government officials
in the bird drone surveillance plot.
It didn't take much to convince the media.
After just one summer
holding rallies like this,
it became nationally syndicated news
on tons of local news stations
that we were a real movement
that had been around for 50 years.
And there was a resurgence happening
where it was coming back
and there was a radical new leader,
myself, bringing the movement back
as the rise of conspiracy theories
swept the nation.
At this point, I'm sitting on my couch,
watching the media report
on my fake movement as a real one
and figure it is probably time
to come out of character.
One, because we'd accomplished
what we came there to do.
But also, I didn't want this to snowball
in anything that was never supposed to.
So in 2021, I broke character,
revealed the movement was a farce
on the front page of The New York Times.
And I was very proud, as you can see.
Allow me to reintroduce
myself one more time.
Hi, I'm Peter.
Can you say, "Hi, Peter?"
(Audience) Hi, Peter.
Hey.
I'd like to tell you
a little bit about myself.
I grew up in Arkansas in Little Rock,
where I was home-schooled
on the outskirts of town.
The community that I grew up with
was hyper conservative and religious,
and almost everyone that I knew believed
in some form of conspiracy theory,
whether it was that Obama
was the Antichrist
or that there are microchips
in the vaccines.
During my entire life, I always felt like
I was on the fringes of normal society.
So, as you can imagine,
when it became time for me
to play a character,
the conspiracy theorist was a pretty
easy one for me to tap into.
During the years in character,
I used the same cadence,
logic and arguments
as those I grew up around,
just with a different theory swapped in.
I was really dedicated to playing
this character as convincingly as I could,
as method as possible.
So I spent days, sometimes, in character,
a lot of time out in public
with the van there,
just talking with strangers.
It led to hundreds
of interactions with strangers
who thought that I was
a real conspiracy theorist.
I'd often be out there, cowboy hat on,
handing out fliers that said things like,
"If it flies, it's spies."
(Laughter)
We had another flyer that said,
"Birdwatching goes both ways."
(Laughter)
And during these times, as I'm handing
out flyers and talking with people,
there were hundreds, maybe thousands
of instances over the years
where strangers would approach me.
You know, they'd see me in public
and I'd see them notice me.
And walk up to me with complete
disdain on their face.
They thought that I was
a real conspiracy theorist.
And time and time again,
they'd come up to me,
look me right in the eyes,
just as close as I am to you right here,
and they would tell me how stupid I am.
They'd tell me I was uneducated,
that I was crazy.
That I was the problem with this country.
When this happens,
I didn't feel the emotions
of the character that I thought I would.
My out-of-character self
may interpret these interactions
as a funny response to someone
that fell for the comedy project,
but instead I felt the emotions
of the character.
I felt emboldened
and I felt sad and angry.
Like they didn't even take
the time to know me.
They instantly condemned me,
judged me and othered me.
I'd found myself on the opposite side
of this equation that I'd grown up around,
the normal and the fringe.
And in those moments
when those people were talking to me,
they could not have been more ineffective
at what I would assume they really want.
Less conspiracy theorists in the world.
These experiences, hundreds
of them over the years,
watching how people interact
with those on the fringes of our society
gave me an entirely new perspective
on our approach to conspiracy theorists,
whether it's how we frame them
in the conventional media,
to how we deal with those
in our own lives.
If our goal is to live in a shared
reality with our neighbors,
what if our current approach
isn't bringing us any closer to that?
What if by talking to conspiracy theorists
like they're ignorant and stupid,
we're actually pushing them
farther away from the truth
that we want them to see?
Because what happens when someone
tells you that you're stupid,
you're all wrong, you're the problem?
You'll feel judged and dismissed.
And most importantly, you’ll feel othered,
which may lead you to look for safety
in those who are like-minded
to do what they have been doing for you.
Affirm your selfhood, give you
a sense of identity, belonging.
These are some of the most
basic human desires.
We have to consider
that conspiracy theorists
are not just joining
these groups for no reason.
They're getting rewards out of these,
things that we are all looking for,
a sense of purpose, community.
I grew up with the internet
and during my time with this project,
especially out of character,
people have talked to me
about the misinformation age
and this, you know, terrifying problem
of online echo chambers
and conspiracy theorists.
But I want to remind us that there are
humans behind a lot of these screens.
It's not just numbers.
Everyone’s unique experience influences
their own narrative about the world,
and there's no blueprint
for how to deal with this yet.
But I do not think that online
echo chambers of conspiracy theorists
are this inevitable
symptom of life online.
The internet is about 30 years old
and things are changing quickly,
and I think it'll be very important
that we develop new solutions
for these new problems
on a fundamental level.
What if by addressing belief
before belonging,
we're starting the conversation
at the wrong place?
Instead of sitting in collective
bewilderment and frustration
about how these people
could believe these things,
these crazies,
what if we first looked under the hood
and thought about what made them
vulnerable to this information
in the first place?
What might they be getting out of this
that they're not getting
in their everyday lives?
How much does it have to do
with a different truth,
or how much does it have to do
with the community that that truth brings?
We need to think
about people's circumstances
and reference points,
to see them as fellow human beings
who want to believe in something
and want to belong,
just like all of us do in this room.
Because if we continue
with our current approach of arguing
on the level of belief,
it's not going to get us anywhere.
We're going to end up
with more echo chambers,
more disinformation and more polarization.
Instead, we can do the harder work
of looking into what is fueling the need
for an alternate truth.
Not only would this lend us more empathy
for those who think differently than us,
but I really think this might be
the only actually productive means,
productive means,
of moving toward the shared reality
that we all want to live in.
Let's direct our energy
toward the crisis of belonging.
And then maybe we will understand
the crisis of belief.
Before I go, I'll leave
with one more word.
Just don’t forget:
if it flies, it's spies.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)